like it was okay for like a good like
five six days and then like the second
half of the quarantine it really starts
to get to you where where you're just
you're just in your house and you're you
know seeing everyone out and you're
seeing the country be normal i guess you
just
luckily i have sydney so i had her to
interact with in case i was feeling too
lonely if i was by myself oh bro i loved
it i had a great time really yeah dude
the dichotomy of man i was like i was
testing like every single ubereats out i
was like i was loving it my new place i
really love and i got to like kind of
work on it a bit and uh i didn't i
didn't
schedule anything yeah so i just had
like the full 11 days to just kind of do
what i want i played some games i mean
you did that like three or four days oh
yeah yeah yeah i did a 72-hour stream oh
yeah you did that guys i didn't say
anything racist in my sleep that was
good well we don't know i muted my mic
so maybe i
could
i saw a lot of mouth flaps
couldn't make it out
yeah i uh i did a 70 70 hour stream not
72 because i had a japanese class that i
had to end it so yeah but i did a 70
hour stream which was uh fun yeah i had
a really good time it was kind of last
minute i was kind of like i'm going to
do
a 70 hour stream and my mods were like
what
you're going to what no you can't do it
it's too soon i was like no we're doing
it we're doing it it's perfect time i'm
going to do it yeah
yeah i mean you're stuck at home right
now it was good i i i by the third day i
was getting quite tired
um i understand now why ludwig would
watch clips for so long because after a
while i just was like can i stop talking
for a bit like can i just stop i'm
getting really tired
but it was fun it was fun i i sleeping
on stream was not as difficult as i
thought it would be
um i was generally just quite tired from
streaming all day yeah i mean it's it's
i kind of just conked out i tuned in
right at the beginning and then again
right at the end and it was like looking
at two different people i was like wait
is this this time
i was starting to get some like really
big uh like bags under my eyes i could
see that because i i think like i wasn't
sleeping like eight hours because it's
very hard to because yeah when you wake
up you want to check make sure
everything's okay
and uh people uh could have had the
ability to [ __ ] with my lights the whole
time yeah so people were like making my
house a rave while i was sleeping yeah
you know that what's that what's that
[ __ ] that meme edit where it's like
the outside of the house and you can
hear the music inside and the lights oh
yeah it's literally like that
but i just played trash taste episodes
while i slept oh wow that was what i did
easy content
when i was sleeping i assumed because
when i was streaming i had about uh 10
to 14k viewers concurrent yeah which was
more than i had normally have i was very
impressed i thought when i was sleeping
it would go down to like okay
there was like 7 000 people watching
this yeah i i i was like i saw that
because like what the [ __ ]
what have you been doing because i was
like going through jet lag and i'm like
let's see what connor's up to he's like
seven thousand people watching me sleep
i was like [ __ ] hell man
normally
my normal streams get like that and i
was like why am i i'm getting more
sleeping what the [ __ ] they're like
sleeping with you like i don't know it
was i know it's like it's like i'm
sleeping next to her i know it was weird
waking up and seeing like people had
subscribed like paid to sub to me while
i was sleeping yeah i'm like right [ __ ]
i should just sleep on stream all the
time i get paid to sleep [ __ ] me like
i'm kidding it's weird though cause i'm
like why did someone give me 50 subs
while i was sleeping it's like 300 quid
more than that i think actually it's a
lot of money i'm like what the [ __ ] like
the most generous tooth fairy in the
world yeah yeah right
i was like what the [ __ ]
what is this what's going on
but it was weird i and i'd have like
weird moments where i would wake up but
i don't remember waking up and i would
see clips of me waking up and i was like
i don't remember that i don't remember
that i saw a clip of you i don't know if
you were half asleep or not but you just
like flipped off the camera
oh
i was trying to sleep right and then
people just went ham with my lights all
right and they just started changing it
every second and then i was just like
[ __ ] you guys
um yeah it was fun though i really
enjoyed it i didn't think uh it was
something i ever thought i'd be
interested in but i thought [ __ ] it i'll
try it and uh i obviously had a lot of
fun i'd recommend you guys try it out no
i'm good i'm good man i like i like my
privacy i i can barely stream i can
barely stream as it is people want
people always telling me they're like
you guys should do a trash tasting where
you just take it and turn streaming and
then like i was like oh you could work
something some time or something i mean
i i feel like if if we did it as a group
it would be easier yeah like by myself
[ __ ] [ __ ] you do shifts like we're
together sometimes but then [ __ ] i mean
i've done like long streams with other
people yeah you know that go for like 15
to 20 hours i couldn't do it by myself i
couldn't do it by myself yeah i don't
know i i i didn't have like many guests
come on i just had uh iron mouse play
with me which was great it's fun when
you have someone else to talk yeah
because that's the thing is like if you
have someone else to bounce off of right
then you don't have to be like so he was
he was likely talking to china the
reasons why i decided to do it um so i
had not been streaming for like a month
before i left for the uk and so i didn't
stream um for a month at all so i didn't
stream for two months and so i have a
second channel as well and we like ran
out of videos we had like no more videos
left and so mudan my editor was like hey
connor please please make like a [ __ ]
ton of content and i was like all right
i got you
so i the 72 hours sorry
i got like like i don't know like 10
plus videos out of it so i'm like there
you go
here you go
he was very happy now he's like great
now i have more content to edit this is
great this is
yeah yeah because we have a we have a we
have a deal where we split the money 50
50. yeah so
yeah that's why he was desperate he's
like i need to give people yeah
the channel has been doing great so he's
like come on connor we've got to keep up
the content it's like because he's like
whipping you from there he's now the guy
who's like come on man i need content
start doing something connor film it and
he's like
and he tells me he's like play this game
it'll be funny for a video yeah all
right okay
he's your content producer now yeah yeah
yeah it's well it's a really good uh
it's a really good um balance because we
kind of started it together because uh
i didn't we were just like okay i won't
pay you for editing fees but you get 50
of whatever it makes and then uh we
thought we'd be in the red for a while
uh or we thought he'd be in there for a
while but luckily yeah it took off and
now it's doing really really well and uh
it's killing it and some of the videos
get like more views than my videos yeah
i saw that one of them got like two
million views now what the [ __ ] should
put this on my main channel
but yeah they're doing really well it's
uh it's cool it's it's weird yeah i
don't know it's uh i mean we also met
mudan in uh the uk as well yeah yeah
we're to catch up with him
somehow he found two days out of his
schedule to uh program himself out of
editing and uh he flew all the way from
estonia to come hang out with us yeah my
god my god he is a machine i i didn't
realize this
i didn't appreciate this until like
actually speaking to him in person
where he is he is insane i've never seen
someone with like a like a more strict
work ethic than he does oh yeah that man
never quits yeah i'm surprised he still
has like emotion
because like you have to like throw
humanity away to keep up with him he had
his videos in full time speed yeah he
watches the video in four times
i was like how do you i don't think
human brain
i am convinced he's just jacked into the
matrix because how do you edit in four
times speed like you don't do that with
a mouse and keyboard you do that like in
like [ __ ] ghost of the show
basically you like jack yourself in and
like he edits the video in his mind
that's that's how i i'm convinced he's
the one with premiere pro he does
editing speed runs on his on his twitch
channel yeah he edits like my whole of
my videos in like four hours yeah
because because like i remember i
remember talking to him when we were
catching up because he was with us and
like with a bunch of our mates as we
were like all catching up um and i was
talking to him and he was and i was like
oh so you're editing for like trash
taste our specials um after connor's
channel conor's second channel and some
of joey's videos and i've heard some of
aki's videos in the past as well and i'm
just like are you close to burnout and
he was like no god i'm looking for more
work do you have more work for me he was
like
what
he said
he's never disconnected and and he was
like god have you ever thought about
starting a stream channel i'm like mood
on how are you looking for more work
right now he told that to me as well he
was like he was like i see you've been
uploading along your second channel uh
do you want do you want me to edit those
and i'm like no i'm good
i'm good enjoy your life please
and and and i'm i was just like i was
just like flabbergasted that this guy is
still looking for more work after how
many goddamn channels he's already
editing for it's like a content black
hole like it just like keeps ingesting
it's never enough
just like
i'm just like i because i asked i asked
him like what what is what is your limit
have you ever limit tested yourself and
he's like no i want to know you've given
me more i'm nowhere near close to my
limit he's got the winner
what the [ __ ] man what what is what is
this machine that i'm talking to you man
it's just like he's like tested like
every productivity app out there to like
find which one is like the most
productive yeah so that he knows like
how he can maximize his productivity
he's insane it's just like a different
breeze like the f it's like a [ __ ]
t-100 skynet didn't send back a [ __ ]
terminator they just sent back moody
dude like like edit every video on earth
on youtube and he won't stop until he
like monopolizes the entirety of any
tube basically
i think if every person was like we'd be
we'd be at like intergalactic travel
stages right now like we'd be so
advanced
[Laughter]
like controlling the solar system
jesus christ
i also feel like we'd be very dystopian
but
i don't know though yeah it was fun i
mean it was uh the whole the whole thing
was fun it was really nice getting to
speak to him yeah
instead of asking to do work
ask him to have a beer
just just hanging out and just uh like
having a beer with him in person that
was that was very nice